За 2,5 роки роботи виконувачкою обов'язків
міністра охорони здоров'я України на Уляну Супрун
сипалося чимало критики від її опонентів.
Перша спроба звільнити її з посади торік у Верховній Раді провалилася.
Нині депутати знайшли іншу лазівку і намагаються
звільнити чиновницю через її американське громадянство.
У чому найбільше звинувачують Супрун та наскільки виправдані ці закиди?
Уляну Супрун відсторонили від виконання обов’язків
міністра охорони здоров’я через наявність у неї
подвійного громадянства - американського та українського.
Тим часом закон прямо не забороняє подвійне громадянство.
Якщо людина, крім українського, має паспорт іншої країни,
то Україна визнає таку людину лише своїм громадянином.
Державні службовці не можуть мати паспорт
іншої країни, але це не поширюється на міністрів
та їхніх заступників. Окрім того, закон вимагає
від іноземця підписати документ, у якому він
зобов'язується відмовитися від громадянства іншої країни.
У МОЗ ще у 2017 році стверджували, що
Уляна Супрун виконала всі вимоги законодавства
для отримання українського паспорта.
Уляні Супрун ставлять в провину те, що вона,
мовляв, забрала в українців право на безкоштовну медицину.
Утім, на практиці медицина в Україні вже давно
не була безкоштовною. Майже половину
загальних витрат на медицину складали витрати
з кишень українців, порахували у VoxCheck.
Тим часом медреформа Супрун передбачає
гарантований пакет безкоштовних медичних послуг.
Зокрема, екстрена і первинна медична допомога,
медична реабілітація, допомога у зв’язку з вагітністю
та пологами тощо. Мета мінохоронздоров'я -
припинити практику неофіційних платежів лікарям.
Головна опонентка Супрун, Ольга Богомолець
з профільного комітету Верховної Ради, звинувачує
відсторонену виконувачку  обов'язків міністра охорони здоров'я
у прискоренні вимирання українців. За даними Богомолець,
у 2017 році померлих було на 198 тисяч більше, ніж народжених.
Це на 23 тисячі більше, ніж 2016 року.
У 2018 році ця тенденція продовжилася. Втім,
скорочення населення України відбувається вже давно.
І причина - не в політиці Супрун, вважають у VoxCheck,
а в загальнодемографічних трендах, коли
на тлі економічних проблем українців народжується менше,
ніж помирає. За даними Держстату України,
у 2018 на 100 померлих припадає 58 новонароджених.
Супрун закидають, що за роки її керівництва
рівень вакцинації впав нижче за показники 90-х років.
Дійсно, рівень щеплень в Україні страхітливо низький.
За даними Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров‘я,
за цими показниками Україна опинилася в компанії Сомалі, Сирії та Нігерії.
У 2017 році вакцини отримали менше половини дітей: 31-40%.
По всій країні лише половина населення має імунітет від дифтерії, кашлюка та правця.
Ситуація дещо поліпшилася наприкінці 2018 року:
вакцинованих від цих же хвороб було вже більше 67%.
Утім, причини невтішної статистики - не в дефіциті вакцин,
а в тому, що багато батьків бояться ускладнень,
неякісних вакцин або просто є противниками щеплень
На сайті мінохоронздоров'я є графік необхідних щеплень,
а також інформація, скільки саме вакцин є у Києві та в областях.
Уляну Супрун також звинувачували в тому, що
медики в країні отримують найнижчу зарплату у світі.
Утім, так було і за попередніх міністрів.
Однак після медичної реформи, яку запровадила Супрун,
зарплати лікарів первинної ланки подекуди зросли удвічі-утричі.
Рівень зарплати залежить від кількості декларацій
із пацієнтами, які підписав сімейний лікар
або терапевт - за принципом "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом".